Lesotho it's a country within a country
the nation whose borders it sits within
is South Africa which historically
certainly had its issues with its
neighbors and before this it was a part
of the British Empire which liked nice
neat borders and wasn't afraid to force
its desired changes on its colonies and
so given its neighborhood its history
and the fact that it's entirely located
within another country this raises a
question why does Lesotho exist and how
did it manage to stay independent so
like many things throughout history
Lesotho can be traced back to Napoleon
as a result of Napoleon being Napoleon
he Incorporated the Netherlands into
France and by extension took its
colonies for his own the British firm
enemies of the French that they were saw
an opportunity to liberate these
colonies and keep them out of French
hands the idea was that these would be
handed back to the Dutch after
Napoleon's defeat and the resumption of
their independence and by hand it back I
mean only the ones that the British
didn't want for themselves the most
notable Colony that Britain kept was
Cape Colony here in southern Africa and
the way that the British ran its new
territory upset the European settlers
who already lived there they promptly
left and settled here which brought them
into contact with the basoto people here
there were a few Wars over the most
fertile land in the region because
starvation sucks and the besuto came off
the worse fearing more losses to the
boars the basuto king mashoa showa asked
the British for protection in 1865 which
they accepted now the British believe
that by asking for protection mashoa
showa was surrendering all of his
country's sovereignty to Britain forever
but that's not how he saw it six years
after providing protection Britain
decided that things needed to change
first the besuto weren't allowed to own
guns anymore because that would mean
that they'd be able to shoot back during
rebellions which wasn't cool and second
besutoland was to stop existing and was
to be incorporated into Cape colony and
third it would be settled at first they
accepted some of this but it wasn't too
long until direct rule was stifling and
so Rebellion Britain was unable to
suppress this Rebellion quickly in doing
so would require a lot more men and a
lot more money as such Plan B concede
and thus basuto land returned to its
former status as a British protectorate
separate from Cape colony and after this
there was no change until the 1960s this
was the point where the British Empire
really started to fall apart and besuto
land gained its independence in 1966 and
it became the kingdom of Lesotho it was
proclaimed a parliamentary democracy
with the basuto National Party in charge
in this Democratic streak would last
until the next election when the
opposition won and so it was time for a
coup this kept prime minister Leia bua
Jonathan in charge with the difficult
time of dealing with his only neighbor
apartheid South Africa Lesotho was
economically reliant on them which is
why it was never annexed the praetorian
government knew that it could
economically hurt Lesotho whenever it
wanted and despite Jonathan's support
for the ANC and other South African
Rebel groups outright annexation wasn't
feasible a direct Invasion would have
seen major International condemnation
and the domestic situation in South
Africa meant that adding hundreds of
thousands more people who hated the
government was not a good idea that said
the praetorian government aided a coup
against Jonathan's government in 1986
and replaced him with a much-friendly
leader who as apartheid collapsed was
himself thrown out of power and
relations normalized and thus after this
the last threats to lesotho's existence
were over I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bizzinette Kelly
moneymaker Mr Wolf Sky Chappelle Adam
Stalter Jordan Longley rod D Martin
Gareth Turner why in hockey Jerry
lambdin Spencer Lightfoot core show wolf
boogly Wiggly Marvin cassar Winston
caywood Gustav Swan Marcus arsner
Captain psydog Aaron the white Matthew
Shipley Robert Wetzel Alex Schwinn
Maggie paxkowski the macquapa Anthony
Beckett Coppertone spinning three plates
Charles the first Ben Evenson Scottish
Trekkie and words about books podcast